Екатерина Шалонская: Алисой. Наш Отведенный. Час?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ah, you are?
Екатерина Шалонская: Сша. Я переключусь минутку?
O!Sapiens Expert: Давай?
Екатерина Шалонская: То у меня в башке не бренда. Косметики?
O!Sapiens Expert: Okay.
Екатерина Шалонская: Подростки, тринадцати, шестнадцати, лет у, которых надо, выявить их более боже ладно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ух?
Екатерина Шалонская: От гайд смотреть?
O!Sapiens Expert: Какие наче более подростков?
Екатерина Шалонская: Ну Да, да, вот. Алиса узнать Удачи Ей, с, Этом?
Екатерина Шалонская: Совсем не, этими то что, там будут только женские интервью с тринадцати шестнадцать лет про косметику жизнь, боле и так, далее?
O!Sapiens Expert: Червозино?
Екатерина Шалонская: Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Интересно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Тож давай, усудим?
Екатерина Шалонская: Вот.
Екатерина Шалонская: Да, у меня, Кстати вопрос женя сказала, что анна Выйдет в начале следующей недели?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ой?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
Екатерина Шалонская: С Бухгалтерскими, штуками и, всеми остальным и. Я забыла ну то, что вбежала колисья. Есть. Ли. Смысл Перенести. Наш разговор на следующую неделю или нет?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, мы можем перенести здесь. Есть. Как минимум. Одна, концептуальная составляющая, которая, ну, которая мы можем, сейчас обсудить остальное в плане Ну, каких деталей может, быть еслительно, перенести на новую неделю но?
Екатерина Шалонская: Торри?
Екатерина Шалонская: Бай?
O!Sapiens Expert: Говоря, про концептуальную, составляющую это но, собственно, наша, с, должность перед тобой относительно премиальных?
Екатерина Шалонская: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Примерно составляющий. Здесь. Нам надо будет поступить несколько хитрым способом потому, что мы естественно не способны, выплатить, тебе их сразу здесь, сейчас, или там момент увольнения, потому что нас просто физически нет денег но, мы эти зайства этого выполним?
O!Sapiens Expert: Другое дело, что для того, чтобы их выполнить нам, надо будет, с тобой сделать соглашение. С самозанятой причем, Это будет не С Ооо, а с Моего Ип, потому что для. О, это будет красный флаг для всех.
O!Sapiens Expert: Органов?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну. Ты. Уже вроде не работаешь и самозанята. Здесь не будут. Работать поэтому это будет ип а второй Момент. До того что нам надо будет с тобой обсудить период течения, которого мы будем выплачивать, потому что, ну, втруюсь, мы, не сможем это сделать свою. Моментно. В идеале, мы бы предложили тебе, это растянуть на?
O!Sapiens Expert: Период шести семи месяцев с, учетом пониманием того что, ну, в, договоре там будет зафиксирована итоговая сумма само. Собой. Которую, мы должны будем выплатить, если вдруг получится выплатить раньше Супер.
O!Sapiens Expert: Но к сожалению, мы, естественно, не можем сейчас, гарантировать какие, то сроки само понимаешь, поэтому этот. Момент собстно нам важно с тобой Как минимум обсудить? Можем Сейчас?
Екатерина Шалонская: Влад, А у тебя Ип Он. У него есть какая то Специализация и, так далее я. Просто думаю типа, меня говорили, что, любое, совместительство, я должна буду проводить через контроль ну типа ну конфликт интересов?
Екатерина Шалонская: Вот через эти хребет?
O!Sapiens Expert: У.
Екатерина Шалонская: Да, и Поэт?
O!Sapiens Expert: Это через службу безопасности. Сбера или чем?
Екатерина Шалонская: Да, я буквально анкету заполняла вступительную и там, был вопрос типа о работе и так далее поэтому мне, здесь. Нужно наверно типа, понять, какой, то, либо, профиль ип либо обговорить, То, же сейчас вопрос?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
Екатерина Шалонская: Вот, чтобы, может быть, это не фиксируют типа, просто, как, таковой?
Екатерина Шалонская: Вот занятость. У меня есть. У меня. Это не смущает сроки. В полгода Меня тоже не смущает. Может, Их, можно сократить. У меня, вопрос, Можно ли я прихватизирую ноутбук?
Екатерина Шалонская: Стоимость, части, процентов?
O!Sapiens Expert: С этим вопросом. Я тебе вернусь на новой неделе потому, что сейчас я эти сразу схода не. Скажу Давай я. По сутим, подумаем, чем ужем сделать?
O!Sapiens Expert: И вопрос по профилю. У меня там. Огромное количество этих видов активности, или как В Эд. Виды экономической деятельности. Соответственно, здесь. Мы, наверно, будем отталкиваться от того что тебе там можно, или нельзя делать.
O!Sapiens Expert: Скажи потому, что, нам ну, в, любом случайно будет сделать договор в договоре там все. Равно. Должна. Печать Прописано да Поэтому, Скажи какие, ограничения и, но, я думаю мы на, этим способ там не знаю если это, слова не маркетинговые исследования. И. Ни, услуги по маркетингу но?
Екатерина Шалонская: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Что то придумаем. Главное, чтобы это было не товарно. Денежное отношения. Товар Потом?
O!Sapiens Expert: Будет слажда где, то. Показать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну, И нет?
Екатерина Шалонская: Окей, То, есть я, сейчас. Моя задача я, Возвращаюсь к этим ребятам спрашиваю какой типа, род. Деятельности, мне, можно делать и так далее или, может, быть, мы решить, это вообще без, регистрации у безопасников как вариант?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
Екатерина Шалонская: Вот я об этом спрошу, И тогда тут. Я к тебе тоже.
Екатерина Шалонская: Вернусь ты вернешься Ко, мне, по полку и мы уже более. Предметны это будем выговаривать. Всего?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, и здесь, еще на будущее ну. Когда, Ты, Будешь, говорить мивой чарли службе безопасности Кем Бы то, Не Было Попробуй тоже понять да насколько, концептуально в, Принципе мы, можем с тобой в будущем работать?
Екатерина Шалонская: Окей. Я, Уточню, тогда там?
Екатерина Шалонская: Окей. Да, я, сделаю?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну Да потому, что, одно дело там вот, это часть премиальными да. Но, другое дело если. Там нам надо будет что то, вдруг довести там, или не знаю вдруг, тебе попросить что, то сделать и, мы. Это, как, то оформим?
O!Sapiens Expert: И если у тебя нет, такой возможности, нам, конечно, лучше это знать на. Берегу?
Екатерина Шалонская: Да, Я Уточню?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей Напомни, Пожалуйста, когда, у тебя в последний день получается?
Екатерина Шалонская: Одиннадцатого сентября?
O!Sapiens Expert: Одиннадцатого сентября. Окей. Я, понял я, Не знаю обсуждал ли ты с, кем, то как то кому коммуницируют, команде все?
Екатерина Шалонская: Скажем на, викли в начале следующей неделе потому что, надо перепланировать загрузку и перепланировать часть передач моих проектов в первую часть ведь. Нова Косметикс Там?
Екатерина Шалонская: Книмова?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
Екатерина Шалонская: Вот поэтому я скажу в начале недели следующей?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей. Хорошо. Тогда Наверное, это, основное, в остальном но удавно, можем подтверждать пк навернешь Отпуск. И продолжим там?
O!Sapiens Expert: Четыре еще кита. Мужчина вопросы?
Екатерина Шалонская: Да окей. Просто, снова?
Екатерина Шалонская: То вроде Нет, типа?
Екатерина Шалонская: Я сейчас. Пойму, что там происходят по самозанятости. Вот у нас будет шесть семь месяцев выплат. Ты вернешься. Ко мне с. Ноутбуком?
Екатерина Шалонская: Аня, говорила что, документами в целом хоть взять не, оформить можем. Здесь. Проблем нет. Ты. Вране, Все?
O!Sapiens Expert: Там. Ну. С, документами чуть послажнее, тому что по, законодательству мы должны, выплатить тебе все то что тебе прочитается будь то там отпускны, или еще чтобы это, не было тут будет завести от конкретной даты. Что у нас зовны деньги? На счете выделя?
O!Sapiens Expert: Можем. Не Знаю подумать как, мы можем там проданглировать тем же ноутбуком но, здесь меня надутся а, не проверь потому, что это, не самая простая схема. Там, Ну, как бы не все так прямолинейно? Дашь. Нельзя прошло взять и, этом вычесть там, надо будет, вероятные, то, документы подписать, может, быть еще что, то?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но короче, с этими схемами. Вернемся.
Екатерина Шалонская: Да окей, Ладно, не, я, Понимаю что там, какие то. Схема с ноутбуком, эту штуку я видела?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Екатерина Шалонская: Ну, Посмотрим?
O!Sapiens Expert: К.
Екатерина Шалонская: Все такое?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, спасибо, давай. Тогда хороших. Те выходных?
Екатерина Шалонская: Кто?
Екатерина Шалонская: И тебя?